um yeah B Final Fantasy 14 online coming
to Xbox series consoles in Spring 2024
and uh during the Final Fantasy Fan Fest
2023 the game director now yashita Yoshi
Pete welcome her Xbox had Phil Spencer
onto the stage alongside Square Enix CEO
Takashi Kiryu to celebrate the Xbox
release announcement for Final Fantasy
14. on stage curio made the following
statement and one more thing as CEO of
Square Enix we want to continue to
deliver fabulous games to fans across
the world and of course we went to
welcome the Xbox Community as well and
starting with today's announcement of
Final Fantasy 14 coming in Spring 2024
and whenever is possible we are planning
to bring our games to Xbox for players
around the world to enjoy we really look
forward to working closely with Phil and
the Xbox team to make this possible in
response Phil Dominus Maximus Aurelius
Spencer Gotta Give Kids thank you Kiri
young song and we deeply respect the
rich Legacy of Square Enix and we look
forward to building on the relationship
that we've established in bringing Final
Fantasy kiggins out of pocket it's not
like a new boyfriend
I really respect you love
sorry you're going on stage with it and
Alfredo Fantasy 14 to the Xbox and
partnering closely with you and the
Square Enix team on future games and
then following that also this week we
saw from the official Final Fantasy um
Twitter account says announcing that uh
Final Fantasy 14 Xbox series X and F
following an open beta test during patch
6.5 we'll proceed to the official
release but it's spring 2024 on Xbox so
this kind of broke late luckily the
Lord's got this new cycle it's been
breaking the internet but I gotta I'm
gonna break protocol a little bit web
Dave because I do have to ask
one particular Lord
you know he he loves these square games
you know we we in a situation that we
probably never have no clue who you're
talking about we never thought this
might happen and then you know the
following week it just happened and this
particular Lord and King we're having a
discussion about Squidward so I gotta
know breaking how's my brother feeling
Lord addict Square Enix Final Fantasy 14
more square games on the on the way and
the public display of Phil Spencer
Square Enix CEOs where are you at with
this well the tears of PlayStation fans
was pretty nice I will say that uh the
second thing I'll say is when it comes
to just this particular announcement
it's cool I see 14 14 is a very beloved
game a lot of people love 14.
I'm just not one of them
so you know I'm glad that
we were able to get that on the platform
because I feel like there's very few
things that will get that much said this
might not get awareness to turn based
final fantasies like the older ones or
or like the newer ones they're giving
out
but this will give awareness to the
Final Fantasy brand on Xbox because this
this world is built entirely around
final fantasies like you know our raid
bosses yeah they're
summonses so you know you you literally
there's raids you fight Bahamas oh
that's fine there's there's so many
raids that have summons for bosses a
variety of things and I do think this is
a phenomenal game to be in Game Pass I
don't I don't want I want wait they
didn't they didn't say Game Pass no but
it's not no I'm just talking about free
to play to level 70. okay I'm just
talking about Xbox in general what I
said Game Pass okay that's the plus my
head
so like when it comes to that I really
enjoy that but I do want people to put a
little bit of a break like just pump the
brakes just a little bit they ain't
doing that because this this doesn't
mean they're bringing remake I do think
this is
I do think this is really good for the
relationship we'll probably see like the
octopus traveler 2 come to the platform
now we'll see you know there is a
rumored Final Fantasy Tactics okay uh
the the original one I think it's the
lion uh Lions war or something like that
I can't remember the the because they
made a Final Fantasy Tactics on the PS1
and then they remade it on the Vita and
I can't remember I think it's Lions
board someone in the chat there's over a
thousand people in that chat hit that
like button so under the chat correct me
what war of Life yeah yeah so I think
that remake probably shows up on Xbox
that maybe not day and date because this
relationship is is relatively new we
might not see the bear of fruit going
into this I don't think it's new I think
they've been dating
well I I I can't exactly exercise stop
being messy yeah I think when it comes
down to this it's very good you know I I
think we'll once these contracts start
to to wear out you'll see Final Fantasy
7 come out and then you know maybe maybe
King right and I have to eat a chip oh
he actually is that it no my my man
ain't eating no chip like on God and
them I don't care you can give me your
knees I don't get help so we do
something else but
um no but let me I gotta ask you this
because
this is for years you've been you've
been on the front line with this you've
been the guy I I made a video yeah I
have over
60 videos talking about
Square Enix games on Xbox like like what
like what was it surprising you like
that like what did it feel did you feel
like yo this is uh they really improved
they're really gonna try to do something
like how does this feel for you you've
been wanting this for so long I had two
thoughts I'm like oh snap
14's coming on Xbox that's crazy and
then my after thought was
but it's not seven rings
it's a good really really good for step
forward it's like I said okay in a lot
of ways having this game come on Xbox is
bigger than having remake come on Xbox
because people don't realize
how popular this game is
insanely popular uh you know they they
you could pick classes from from all the
final fantasies just about you know in
Final Fantasy 10 Oren has like this
right uh this red I think it I don't I
don't know exactly what but the name of
it would be like they they go to that
detail like you can get the stuff that a
lot of the Final Fantasy characters wear
like it it's an understatement to say
this isn't one of the most popular MMOs
that's in existence right now wow and
it's never been on Xbox like you know
and I think that this game coming is
just it coming to Xbox is going to give
way more
presence and awareness on Xbox because
it's free to play up to level 70. and
you're able to just jump in there it's
going to get more Awareness on the Xbox
brand of Final Fantasy than Final
Fantasy 7 remake would okay yeah because
remake is just one game
you play Final Fantasy 14 you're you're
meeting characters from the other games
yo what what's what's this dude in here
for what game he go to you know what I'm
saying like I think it'll give more
regulation in the long run but until we
started this is uh chess not checkers
it's it's this is like
setting this is like
starting out with the pawns first like
like and and I do think that this is
going to
set a domino effect where hopefully
you'll see maybe not the final fantasies
that score Enix is is has secured but
like I said the octopi traveler twos the
Final Fantasy 9 remake keep in mind
there's more remakes it's not just
ending at seven so they're trying to
stop them gains from missing Xbox and
then you like I said Final Fantasy
Tactics uh War of the Lions remake
that's that's rumored to be coming and
not to mention Dragon quests they're
trying not to stop them from not coming
to the friends before yo and it's like I
said
if they bought Square Enix
I don't think it's happening but if they
bought Square Enix
I played Tetris for a whole two hours
look this is this is a big deal I'm glad
that you got your perspective let's go
back to normal format with our guest
Lord Webb Dave you know don't know how
your connection is with square you know
square games in general but just you
know how do you feel about this news
what the significance of this news with
uh Phil Spencer and obviously Square
Enix this uh Fan Fest in this kind of
public statement you know forward-facing
statement towards the community
it is big really big
um I mean
this is something that we've been
wanting on and Phil commented on
that they wanted to have happen 10 years
ago when it first came out
so it is uh it is
hard to
there was one uh video that's going
around on Twitter of of a person who was
watching the show and when he they
announced Phil Spencer
and you could see it on his face Phil
Spencer and then he just starts going so
crazy and excited and then crying at one
point and people like he's excited over
Phil Spencer he's like no he's he's a
super passionate gamer about Final
Fantasy 14 and his the realization that
the game that he loves is finally coming
to the platform he loves that was
just cross play too yes exactly cross
play so now you can play because
my son and my daughter both play the
hell out of 14. really and uh and
already in fact well we have we have
messages already going there like you
know so they're gonna
help me level
they're gonna carry you through the
destiny raid I love this I love this
they're gonna carry the old man I love
this
exactly exactly because it's it's you
know like I said I was 11 for a long
time really big fan of playing 11 and uh
you know 14 is is good and and I know
like uh miles Don Pierre was saying that
you know maybe this means that they can
bring games uh like the Mana series you
know and there's a lot of those and and
maybe you know they've already announced
that it's coming you know Kingdom Hearts
four well maybe now Kingdom Hearts four
can make its you know can make its way
to uh to Xbox which would be great
because the other ones have been on Game
Pass at one time so real quick go ahead
Dave I'm looking up like The Raid like
big bosses that's in you got the
Ultimate Weapon uh Behemoth the thing
that was in 15. Odin you got Ifrit Titan
guard uh Gardia I definitely butchered
that you guys can make fun of me it's
funny yeah okay uh no Sheva you got um
Phoenix another Odin like this this
isn't just a game that this is a game
that's heavily dipped in the Final
Fantasy sauce
the lore continue Dave yeah I agree that
that's huge any other uh statements oh
you were good
it's really good for the gaming
community
and for Phil to make a special
appearance there it shows to me yes
and the end of the world of gamers
go ahead Kingdom Hearts four
right that that that's a game that is
probably gonna come out the next couple
years and this early work might lead to
that game not skipping the platform it's
a good point that was a good point well
I hear what Dave was saying in reference
to
um you know the symbolism right so if
Phil be in there so I gotta get to
Lord's SOB I'm very curious
you know Final Fantasy 14 coming to
series X more square games on the way
what are your thoughts on this one
yeah like I said yesterday on uh on
Khalif show like it's shout out to Phil
and the team for doing the work I think
the sad part about it is that they had
to do the work because if you look at
you look at the relationship in the 360
generation even going into the beginning
of the Xbox one generation we still got
you know
right after ff12 we got 13 right 14
skipped it but I understand why 14
skipping Xbox initially because it was
it's an MMO you build it for one
platform and then you see where it goes
from there right it's a lot it's a lot
of money and resources and time to build
an MMO for multiple platforms especially
when you talk about the console space
and not the PC space which is just a
bigger sort of platform unto itself so I
understood that but beyond that
everything was coming to the to the to
the console you know Kingdom Hearts
three came day and date right to Xbox so
it's just it just sucks that the work
had to be done because somewhere along
the lines that relationship broke down
and the communication wasn't there and
and for whatever reason you know and
then you start besides the the cultural
stuff where it's like oh Xbox players
don't like those type of games which is
BS
um you have to you know you have to get
around that whole narrative and
conversation and Phil has to you know
basically go in there and tell them why
it's beneficial to put their games on
the on the platform and he managed to do
it yeah he managed to do it with a game
that is still super popular all these
years later
um but you can't really say no to having
a larger player base when you have an
MMO right like that's why I laughed a
couple weeks ago we had Jazz we was
talking about he didn't want anybody to
touch his precious World of Warcraft oh
my God you bugging
man listen you need as many eyes on this
as possible so I you know I'm not gonna
play it it's not for me I'm not going to
delve into all that but the fact that
it's gonna be there right is is a huge
huge deal and it does bode well for
everything else coming down the pipeline
even the stuff that we that Xbox has
been sort of uh you know denied
opportunity are you implying that former
denied games could be should be between
the Xbox it absolutely should be there's
no reason PlayStation have no horse in
this race at this point when it comes to
ff7 like I shouldn't especially not the
original the the original remake right
um we didn't see the contracts though
what if the car yeah it was like a death
Loop situation
I should I would hope not I see it I
understand why right I understand why
right but with Phil saying more games
are coming yes my hope is that that was
one of the first things on the table
right that in 16.
um right and unless there is some you
know ground and stone uh contracts that
cannot be undone or anything like that
nature and at the very least he is
talking about the stuff the addict was
talking about the stuff down the
pipeline to make sure that is coming to
the console uh day and day right and
then you have the game pass equation and
I will say this right let's say let's
say Phil going over there all these
years I mean trying to you know reforge
this relationship let's say that's still
been a tough sell just for the business
aspect of it right Xbox is in spend mode
bro they're in spend mode and they are
not obviously they're not above having
to be like listen man if you're telling
me we need to help you build the version
for Xbox because it's monetarily you
feel it's not in your best interest the
return is not going to be what you
wanted to be we will do that right and I
see Phil laying down on that sword and
be like hey man do you do we need to see
these games on this platform it is what
it is so I can see that being a scenario
as well where they're helping to build
these Xbox versions of these games
monetarily real quick well I want to
push back on that is
I I'm okay with them making that those
initial pushes but what I'm scared of is
like in the long run
those companies feel comfortable with
Microsoft paying for the ports every
time oh 100 okay because then it's like
I think that's just putting a Band-Aid
on on a bro on a cut because it's not
going to fix the issue because what's
going to happen is now I've got used to
like one or maybe two iterations of a
game a couple installments and then when
Microsoft's like when we're not paying
for the for for it anymore we're not
going to continue to pay for your ports
that's actually kind of your job then
okay we're not doing it no more well
this no I don't think that's gonna
happen you know why because I I think
that's a conversation field goal Phil's
going into this conversation knowing
that full well and if he's willing to do
that this is this is going to be hey
when we see this level when we see this
level of engagement right
well at that point
the proof is in the pudding and you're
going to have that level of engagement
on this platform moving forward you
should be able to Port these games
yourself and we'll we'll talk about
money at that point but I don't think
there's any need for us to now have to
support that development because it's
we're showing you that the platform is
viable for your game right all that old
stuff that you were throwing out at us
cool got you not anymore and I and I see
I can see that argument happening at it
but I see Phil already being prepared
for that I feel you I feel you it could
be just like you know conditions that
like you know we have no problem or
maybe they're one of those things like
you know we'll keep fronting the bill
until you start seeing an audience on
our platform then yeah 100 when we hit
that then you'll start fighting a bit
that's 100 if that is the scenario right
or a scenario
I see that the battle of the monster
Hearts oh
this is to see who could be the weakest
Master yeah this is the thing about you
came though right look at you you don't
know how to win yeah you can't win
nicely no we can't win
you get a W's
here it's my win I do with it like Let
me refresh my memory did they close the
deal the next day like you said they
were going to
um I I thought the deal was gonna close
the Monday after okay okay
sometimes sometimes
this is for you
yeah
yeah sir yo so now so now Phil going in
with a contingency plan is mustard heart
he went in there and he went in there
through the meat on this
all I'm saying is Phil Spencer said the
baddest who could who he himself has
said I've been over there for years
trying to reforms this all of a sudden
he went over there with meat on the
table again beef that's that's how I
went down it didn't go down that way you
know you know what's funny and you know
where to go down muster Hearts like to
revise whatever they want to do
I just I just listen y'all guys talk and
I was doing the battle of the mustard
heart s
continue to continue to muscle that's
all I'll say all I'm saying it may
behoove you someday to take o w with a
bit of humility
I'm not doing that I'm gonna take my w
how I like it I like I like my w with a
little sauce
[Laughter]
you don't like my W's hey
what the hell's a slathery Monster yeah
only thing you do remember is these wins
oh my God so let King go so that he
could oh basically reiterate what I say
and try to say basically obliterate try
and base it and try to say it in a
different way that makes it sound like
Phil walked in there with his chest out
because he didn't do that I'm gonna show
you where you're wrong I'm gonna tell
you right now and you know what's over
there
coming out in the middle
all right
[Laughter]
you you know obviously the the
discussion last week was very prophetic
because um we we did talk about Square
Enix and you had some very strong
proclamations you you had abandoned knee
I will say I went from zero percent
chance of that happening to like at 15
now we gotta give King his flowers we we
all looked at him again like we always
do when he makes both Proclamation
sometimes like yo that's wild he really
saying this like acquisition or Square
Enix without any information and then
boom and who shows up on stage like King
I gotta like what is going through your
mind right now when you see Phil Spencer
on stage with Square Enix heads talking
about this relationship and let's be
clear this relationship has been Rocky
and inconsistent at best for the last
couple of years so what do you make of
this and do you still stand on your
theory that there's going to go let's go
check it out the only thing that's been
Rocky and inconsistent was the old CEO
um
money was on the table this is before
the AKA
um ABK deal money was on the table yo
listen we want to do this we want to do
that we want to purchase this and it was
a deal in place
Microsoft came back to the table
so yo like nah we need more bread on
that like it's not you you saw somebody
wallet before they left and they came
back you raised the price oh man so
that's what the the talks was breaking
down then ABK uh became available and it
was like let's let's go handle that real
quick we can double back on these dudes
there was a point in time where
tons of uh Square Enix games was showing
up on Game Pass that is true and nobody
thought that you would get uh any of the
Kingdom Hearts series on Game Pass like
all of them showed up and then all these
obscure Final Fantasy games started
showing up and we was like yo what's
going on with this relationship where
they going with it well come to find out
when the APK information came out the
stuff that Sony did not want you to see
um somebody had a whole dossier
that it's true they pulled out this is
the square folder
and in that folder they had everything
all the ins and outs and they were
approved for purchase like they were
this is the higher-up said yeah we see
what y'all doing we like that we
purchased them
okay so that information is there so we
trying to figure it out like oh snap all
right so the double back happened so
what happened what do you think happened
wrong so as soon as this time these
dudes is over there they feel like all
right back on the grind grind never
stops when you're a hustler never stops
so he was like all right back to what I
was talking about back to my regularly
scheduled program went right over back
to Japan new CEO in place new CEO in
place I forget the gentleman uh carry
you and um yeah the former he took over
from uh what's his name yasuki Masada so
he stepped down as president and then
Takashi Kiryu is now the new president I
believe the timing was very interesting
in conjunction to this announcement
because I believe it's um he the new CEO
started in June and Final Fantasy 14
Xbox announced in July
I used to watch called bunk and there
was an episode where the mayor what
what's the thing would you do when you
get someone out of jail you um hardened
them yeah so there's a criminal that the
mayor wouldn't pardon so that kerm's
like we gotta get that mayor about it
because we have chosen a success
it's like we can't buy the company so
we're gonna buy the league they put a
new guy that's a little bit more
agreeable no no no no I don't I don't
even think what you're saying is is
factual what you think I'm just joking
no no no no they will I don't think they
literally went in there and said we're
gonna no that's gonna give you a
paycheck to get it hard version of it
but let me give you the real version of
it
we want to be sold the boy like we want
to be sold we don't pretty up ourselves
we don't we don't separate it from Iowa
we don't did all this other stuff
Dynamics with everybody gone and we
don't have the person in place that got
to keep vetoing what we want to do so
you know what we're gonna give you all
if you can't refuse you got to get up
out of here and um you take this
severance package you disappear the
moment that he takes a severance package
and disappear the most uh accoladed MMO
is showing up Final Fantasy 14. they had
a private investigator to walk in for
like are these you in these pictures you
know what he said yo the distance they
had the dossier and he slid it out and
said
in this shot was this was this you
hitting her
oh
he said he said
um wait Phil went over there with with
the footage with the tape put it on the
table and said
it wasn't even filmed the investigator
leaves then Phil walks in and fills this
down so what's up yeah they did your
silky like that by Suicide like that
yeah so so shout out
and the new CEO I'm greeting Phil if
y'all look at the the the um the picture
when they all hold their hands with the
Kumbaya yes yes
they had to show you on the stage
this is real this is happening for days
I said something about lifting something
at an envelope and king oh so happened
listen I'm I'm about that life I'm about
this podcast in life you call it I got
it but
the thing about it is Phil is ready he's
not he's not about going to Japan and
playing around and having drinks and not
making moves he's there to make moves he
came out of the wrestler's tunnel people
to arouse and Applause so we're gonna
have all right to help with all the
monster heart talk everything's showing
up B every day everything is showing up
everything Final Fantasy
you're saying a bag wasn't involved in
it no no listen money's always involved
in everything that's what I said no but
no no no no no no no no no no you said
it must have harder way
not like how you not like how you
talking though
everything's coming
watch this right
watch when that ABK deal is complete
who's next everybody keep yelling out
Sega no Sega next in line
there was
there was a dossier bro like if you go
into the into the FBI uh Department
these faces no they have a folder with
your face on it yo imagine imagine that
it's next time like you go into that
thing and ABK goes in there it's like yo
why is there an X over our logo oh cause
we got you
yo look like the dossier if if you want
to tell everybody about Adrian's office
and your face is on a folder start
getting your Affairs in order
they got information
do you find this weird this is this is
not weird this is not coincidence the
next people they pick up is square the
next day gonna go buy them outright
whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen
so if you have those little contracts in
the background and final fantastic can
never make it when we buy you and guess
what's gonna happen
what I love about Phil
Dominus Maximus really expensive first
of its name who did that for you kid huh
who did that for y'all who Who had who
when y'all when y'all boot up that Final
Fantasy
I play Final Fantasy on my PlayStation I
mean the service was trash but this guy
said
I want this because like addict said
this is gonna give me the most
visibility
I don't want a one and done
I want something that's gonna last in
perpetuity that Final Fantasy is
associated with this console so once I
get the millions of MMO players over
here then check that out and have that
Curiosity then we're gonna release the
hounds on them
when they purchase Square
I just want y'all all to come back here
and just give me my flowers I told you a
week before it happened what was gonna
happen then you're so like on a Thursday
like Phil is outside and he's holding
hands on the stage and all PlayStation
dudes uh we don't really like 14 anyway
shut up I'm so tired I'm so tired of you
you you hold everything cherished to
your heart and what Phil is doing is
he's little by little removing all the
cards out of your hands best hand of
Yu-Gi-Oh I've ever seen in my life my
guy he put that death card down you know
that card that you can't move left and
you can't move right and that Dragon
come out and nothing that you do is ever
gonna stop it that's when you're
becoming app and my app predictions for
you guys is happening every day and it's
exhilarated nothing for this King
they're coming for this I just had to
put on a Crown because y'all forget who
I am sometimes yeah
and Phil went over there and said
I want you
and I'm gonna have you